hey there townscapers and welcome back
to my channel thank you so much for
stopping by
if this is your first time here i want
to thank you for stopping by as always
it's greatly appreciated and i want to
give you a really big welcome
so today i wanted to let you guys know
that i plan to do a contest starting
next week i got the idea from a viewer
by the name of the blue bubble
and they were just so nice so shout out
to the blue bubble for this idea
uh go show them some love their channel
should be in the upper right corner of
this video and i will also place a link
in the description
but anyways they mentioned that i should
do this and
i thought it would be so awesome but i
had to figure out how i wanted to go
about it because it would be different
from my last contest so
the plan is to host a paint over contest
i will have a website available where
you can download screenshots of some
builds and you can create a paint over
of your own to present
i am currently working on the website
and it should be ready by next week so
just give me a little bit of time and
i'll post a video letting you all know
how to enter into the contest and how
long it will last so on and so forth so
if you enjoy making paint overs or if
you have ever wanted to try it out for
yourself
and you also want a free copy of
townscaper for yourself or someone else
wants it then you are welcome to join i
love paint overs i think they're really
really cool
i wanted to try them myself but i just
haven't done it i have a drawing tablet
but
it's kind of wonky so i need to get a
new one if i actually want to
join in on the fun but um that's it for
this video it's going to be pretty short
i just wanted to make a quick
announcement
if you don't want to miss the contest
please do subscribe to the channel so
that way you'll know when i upload the
announcement and you can get ready to
enter
also please share this video with other
people if you think they may want to
enter the contest as well
i think that would be really awesome to
get as many people to join as possible
and i'm excited so again i want to thank
you so much for viewing it's greatly
appreciated and i will see you next time